>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Muhannad Salhi: Good
afternoon everybody.
Thank you all for coming.
Sorry about the delay.
My name is Muhannad
Salhi and on behalf
of the African/Middle
Eastern Division
and our chief Dr. Mary-Jane
Deeb I would
like to welcome you
all to our event.
Just a few words about our division.
Our division is divided
into three sections.
The African section, which
deals with Sub-Saharan Africa.
The Hebraic section, which deals
with the Hebraic and
Judaic world-wide.
And the Near East section, which
deals from Kazan in the north
to Hatune in the south, Kashgar in
the east, to Casablanca in the west.
So as you can see, we
have our hands busy.
We deal with about 78
different countries
and about 35 different languages.
So I would urge all of you who
are interested in our areas
to come here and do your research.
I would also like to urge you to
check out our four corners blog
and check out our Facebook.
Like us on Facebook.
We also have a number of
noon-time programs like this,
and without further ado I'd
like to introduce my colleague
Ms. Nawal Kawar who is going
to introduce our speaker.
>> Nawal Kawar: Well,
thank you all for coming.
I'm so glad and thrilled to
have two dynamic speakers.
Laila Haddad is parking,
as you all know.
And Maggi Schmitt.
I'm going to introduce
Maggi Schmitt first.
Maggi Schmitt is a writer,
researcher, translator,
educator, and social activist.
She works in various media.
Writing, production,
photography, and video.
Using everyday life as a way
to approach complex political
and social realities.
She co-authored the acclaimed
documentary cookbook The Gaza
Kitchen: A Palestinian Culinary
Journey which has reached an
astonishingly large and diverse
audience with this peculiar blend
of intimate antidotes, political
analyses, and local food ways.
Which is the topic of this program.
The hybrid approach
mixing scholarship
with fresh first person narratives
is characteristic of Maggi's work.
She was one of the creators
of [foreign word] --
am I pronouncing it right?
A Madrid based project that
used innovative methods
of collective storytelling
and cartography
to show the changing
relationship between work and life
for young woman in the city,
creating not only a much cited book,
but film and also knitting
together with a network
of mutual support in the process.
In the same spirit,
she initiated a project
that brought together feminists from
various Middle Eastern countries
to visit each other's spaces
and conduct in depth interviews
with each other about political
strategies and personal lives.
Creating a small archive of stories
and strong network of allies.
Ms. Schmitt has worked
extensively on the issue
of migration and discrimination.
Domestic work and the
economy of care
and the uses of space in the city.
She has participated in
various documentaries
and social research projects,
as well as grass roots initiatives
addressing these issues both
at home, in Madrid, and in
broader European networks.
Recently her work has focused
largely on food and music.
In addition to the Gaza Kitchen
and the other ongoing research
on the political -- on
the politics of food --
do we have politics on food?
[Inaudible].
She did research and production
for the collaborative music
and project Beyond
Digital in Morocco,
looking at the contemporary Berber
folk revival and its relationship
to digital technology and
creating the video elements
of the related app Sufi plug-ins.
She might like to elaborate
on the project later on.
Ms. Schmitt has also taught in a
number of context, an author --
an outdoor -- sorry, an outdoor
education program in Lebanon.
Courses on Mediterranean history
for university students in Madrid.
Courses on post-Colonialism
and feminist theory
in community run continuing
education programs.
She's a member of the group Zenobia
Translations, which specializes
in the translation
and interpretation
of political and scholarly work.
Ms. Maggi Schmitt grew up in Miami,
Florida and has lived in Spain
for most of her adult life.
With extended periods of time also
in Lebanon, Turkey, and Morocco.
She holds a B.A. from
Harvard in Literature
and has conducted advanced graduate
studies in social anthropology
and Mediterranean studies at the
Universidad Autonoma de Madrid.
She now makes her home in a mountain
village near Madrid where she lives
with her partner Yeoman
and their two young sons.
Laila El-Haddad is an award winning
Palestinian author, social activist,
policy analyst, and journalist.
She frequently speaks on the
situation in Gaza, the intersection
of food and politics,
and contemporary Islam.
She has written for
numerous newspapers
and magazines including
the Baltimore Sun ,
Washington Post ,
International Herald Tribune ,
The New Statesman , The
Daily Star , [foreign word],
and has appeared
on many international broadcasting
networks including NPR and CNN.
She's the author of Gaza Mom:
Palestine Politics, Parenting,
and Everything In-between ,
and co-author of the critical
acclaimed The Gaza Kitchen:
A Palestinian Culinary
Journey which was the recipient
of Best Arab Cuisine Book.
Awarded for the Gorman
Magazine, and a finalist
of the 2013 Memo Palestine
Book Awards.
Ms. El-Haddad has lectured to
student groups, academic faculty,
community groups, and non-profits
around the U.S. and the world
on topics ranging from Gaza culinary
history, the situation in Palestine,
as well as her own personal journey
as a former Palestinian
blogger and journalist.
In her spare time she
volunteers in her own community
with Syrian refugees relief and
resettlement efforts in [inaudible],
as well as advocating for
Palestinian rights and equality
through her involvement
with various community
and national groups including the
U.S. Campaign for Palestinian Rights
and the American Muslim
for Palestine.
From 2003 to '07, Ms. El-Haddad
was the Gaza correspondent
for Al Jazeera English
and a regular contributor
to the BBC World Service.
During which time she covered such
events as the Gaza disengagement
and the 2006 Palestinian elections.
Even though we are mentioning all
these programs she's involved with,
I like to tell the audience that
we are not going to get involved
in any controversial topics
or political questions please.
We don't get involved in politics.
During this time, she co-directed
two Gaza based documentaries
including the award-winning
Tunnel Trade .
She's also a policy
advisor with El Shebeka,
the Palestinian policy network.
Through her work as a
writer and documentarian,
she provides much needed insight
into the human experience
of the region.
She was recently featured
in CNN program Parts
Unknown with celebrity chef
and guest [inaudible]
Anthony Bourdain
in the episode titled
Jerusalem, The West Bank,
and Gaza as his guide
in the Gaza Strip.
Marking the first time a mainstream
American audience has seen Gaza
in this ordinary light.
Ms. El-Haddad received her
B.A. in Political Science
and Comparative Area Studies
with a minor in History
from Duke University in 2000,
and her master's in Public Policy
from the Harvard Kennedy
School in 2002.
She was the recipient of
the Clinton Scholarship
and the Barbara Jordan Award
for Women's Leadership.
She's also the recipient
of The American French
Services Committee Inspiration
for Hope Award, and the Arab
Anti-Discrimination Committee's
Literary Leadership Awards.
Born in Kuwait to Palestinian
parents from Gaza,
she currently lives in Clarksville,
Maryland with her husband Yassine
Daoud and their three children.
When not containing the
blissful cowls of her household,
you will frequently find her poking
around other people's kitchen,
in a forest, or on
a basketball court.
Without further ado, Ms. Maggi
Schmitt and Laila Haddad please.
[ Applause ]
>> Maggi Schmitt: All right.
>> Laila El-Haddad: We apologize
for those really extensive
and long bios.
We really didn't think they were
necessary, but we were pressed
and told we have to have them.
Anyway.
>> Maggi Schmitt: The biography
is always an embarrassing moment.
But, so welcome.
Thank you very much for being here.
Again, so sorry for the delay.
As you've heard, we're here
to speak about this book
that we published initially
almost five years ago.
The second edition has just been
released by Just World Books.
It's a much larger, more extensive
edition with more photography,
additional recipes, et cetera.
So we're very, very pleased
to see this finally in print
on nice quality paper
and everything.
So -- and delighted to speak
about it to you all today.
The project was born basically each
of us from our different angles,
from our different life experiences,
from our different relationship
with the region, as a response to
what people usually imagine or know
about Gaza which is sort of this.
This -- these are the
typical images that one sees.
Anonymous, distant, always
shown either as a hapless victim
or as a somehow dangerous aggressor.
And this doesn't resonate
certainly for Laila who's from Gaza,
with her experience of the place.
Didn't resonate with my
brief experience of the place
on an initial visit
that I made in 2009.
And for both of us what really
grabbed our attention about Gaza,
what we felt like was an important
story to tell about Gaza is not --
and yes, Nawal, we will avoid the
sort of over political polemic,
but it's impossible to
speak about the Gaza Strip
without in some way speaking
about its political situation
because it's so overwhelming.
That's all there is.
>> Laila El-Haddad: I feel
like there should be a hot
cold button, like the closer --
>> Maggi Schmitt: The closer
we get to controversy.
But for us the question was to
-- precisely by writing a book,
a cookbook, a sort of
ethnographic documentary cookbook,
was to avoid the sort of big
discourses of official politics
and look at daily life,
ordinary life.
How are people surviving?
How are households staying sane?
How are people continuing with their
lives every day in extraordinary
and truly terrible circumstances?
>> Laila El-Haddad:
With the understanding
that all that stuff exists.
Right? It's not in
a vacuum obviously.
But kind of the idea was how do we
tell the story in a different way?
Sort of the same old story,
but in a different way,
using a different lens.
A lens that is, you know, more
meaningful, that is more humanizing,
that is more dignifying
for, you know,
the people that we were
-- the subject of this.
>> Maggi Schmitt: And it helped --
I mean the interesting thing about
the reception of this book is
that it clearly helps an
audience not familiar with Gaza
to understand this place
in its every day humanity.
But also for the people
we interviewed,
for the people we talked to there,
they've really embraced the book
as a representation of their place
and their lives that they recognize.
And the way that most of the sort
of mediadic representations of Gaza,
they don't recognize
their daily life in that
because it's often
pictures like this.
So, what we always say is we were
sort of trying to sneak in anyone
of those anonymous block windows and
get into the inside of households.
The inside of daily life,
and begin talking from --
fr om something as tactile
as material, as human,
as every day as for
example, the baking of bread
or the cooking of the daily meal.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Which is often
where the real stories get told
and where the histories
are perpetuated.
Right? And where ultimately
dignity is retained.
It's the sort of one safe
space that we frequently
like to say people have sort of --
when everything else
seems sort of out
of your control you do
exercise an element of control
in how you bake your bread or what
ingredients you're using to purchase
to make those -- you know, the
food that you've always known
or what stories you are
sharing and meals you're making.
And so it's liberating
in that sense.
>> Maggi Schmitt: And as we -- as
we undertook the fieldwork for this
which was several months of
fairly intensive fieldwork,
talking to different individuals
who were incredibly generous.
Inviting us into their homes.
We tried to get a sort of a cross
section of Gazan society which goes
from very humble households,
rural households to very --
an urban elite of very accomplished
people and wealthy households.
We tried to cover a whole spectrum.
Discussing with them --
basically asking for recipes,
talking about family recipes and
family techniques for cooking.
But of course as you
all surely know,
recipes are never just how
do you make a given food.
They always drag along with them
on the one hand family stories,
histories, where do things come
from, what do you remember?
I remember my mother-in-law taught
me this, but she said that it --
so you begin to pull on
long threads of history
and those long threads are
invariably connected also
to the circumstances of people's
lives, how they've changed,
when they've moved, when
they've been exiled,
when they've been pushed
from one place to another.
The sort of vicissitudes and ups and
downs of their economic conditions,
their household conditions.
So all of these stories kind
of come along with the recipes.
>> Laila El-Haddad: And we do
remind people over and over again
in the book that again,
it's about sort
of getting beyond these caricatures
and getting a true deeper
understanding not only
of the people themselves,
but of the place.
Right? And we remind people
that Gaza historically is a very
rich -- is a very rich place.
It was a trading city.
It was a main port
along the Mediterranean.
It was a place through which, you
know, all major caravan routes
and spice routes passed
including the Frankincense route
and on and on.
So it has a very unique and
storied place in history.
And it's very difficult to remember
that obviously in the context
of everything that we know
is happening these days.
>> Maggi Schmitt: But it's
very easy to remember this
when you're looking at the recipes.
And this is again --
>> Laila El-Haddad: Kind of
tying those two things together.
>> Maggi Schmitt: We kind of felt
like we had stumbled
upon a secret wormhole,
a secret door into a different
way of telling history.
Because if you simply smell the
rice cooking, how could you not know
that this had been [foreign
word] of he spice trade?
How could -- so in the same way that
recipes tell us family histories,
and therefore economic histories,
and therefore political histories,
they also tell us sort of
great global histories.
You know, the fact of all of
these spices here being integrated
and now -- I mean in the last
month we've been doing sort
of more historic research, and
the resonance's of Gazan cuisine
with Medieval Abbasid
cooking, the same --
we can find these same recipes.
In some ways Gaza --
>> Laila El-Haddad:
Sometimes with the same names,
although somewhat different
ingredients, yeah.
>> Maggi Schmitt: So it's
also kind of a backdoor access
to a broad historical
spectrum of the place.
It's relationship, as Laila says,
in the spice routes,
in the trade routes.
Its relationship to different
courtly cuisine's and different sort
of power structures over history.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Arabian caravans
would obviously pass through
or maybe it's not common knowledge,
but from Arabia they would then go
to Gaza, and it was known that,
you know, the grandfather's --
the grandfather of the
Prophet Muhammad was --
died there and so on and so forth.
And it was -- this is very different
we should mention then elsewhere
in historic Palestine.
The cuisine differs remarkably.
There's certain components
that altogether absent --
that are present in Gaza
that are altogether absent
in other parts of Palestine.
And this was what I
think was so interesting
to us and to so many people.
Why did this happen?
Why was this the case?
You know, how did it come about
and why was it preserved
through the years?
>> Maggi Schmitt: So the
strategy of the book is to tell --
provide the recipes and of course
that in itself is an undertaking
because the translation from
the oral history and the sort
of folk knowledge of you take a
little bit of this and just enough
of that and you do it and you
sauté it until it's done.
>> Laila El-Haddad: And then we
would say like explain how --
>> Maggi Schmitt: How
do you translate that?
>> Laila El-Haddad: It's
like, what are you a moi?
Why do you need me
to explain to you --
>> Maggi Schmitt: You
know when it's done.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Should
just be common knowledge,
you should understand
how this is done.
Yeah.
>> Maggi Schmitt: We
all have grandmother's.
We all know that that's
how cooking is transmitted.
But then, translating that kind
of knowledge into the written kind
of knowledge of a cookbook and,
you know, teaspoon measurements,
and how many minutes and so
on is a whole paradigm shift.
So we did the kitchen testing
and Laila the lion's share of it.
And from the recipes we received in
interviews with these different --
mostly women, some men -- we
documented, and wrote down,
and sort of formalized
those recipes.
Which was a real labor of
love for this Gazan cuisine.
A lot of people have told us
that they're really pleased
to see these recipes
that nobody's ever heard
about now sort of documented
forever.
And for us it was important
to recognize that body
of folk knowledge that's
mostly in the hands of women.
Never really acknowledge -- I mean
everyone's proud of their food,
but it never sort of makes the leap
into what gets recognized
as knowledge.
And so to acknowledge that body of
knowledge as knowledge and write it
down is sort of -- recognizes
its dignity and its importance
to generations and generations.
So that was one of the kind
of legs of what we were doing.
>> Laila El-Haddad:
Sorry about that.
>> Maggi Schmitt: Another was
the photographic documentary part
as you see in this photo.
It was important to us to
document absolutely mundane spaces.
The absolutely ordinary.
Kitchen sinks.
>> Laila El-Haddad:
We have documentary style
photography throughout the book.
The point wasn't to make it this --
I mean it was to be a beautiful
book, but not in the sense
of like sort of these really
photo finished, you know,
images of what we sort
of call food porn.
I mean it was sort of -- it's very
ethnographic documentary in nature.
To give you a real sense of like
ordinary life and ordinary kitchens,
and markets and so on and so forth.
>> Maggi Schmitt: And then also
it was important to us to look
as we said, to trace some of those
personal stories and kind of pull
on those threads and follow
them -- follow them upwards,
out from the immediacy of how
do you make a cauliflower stew?
To look at well, how
much does the meat cost
and how much did it used to cost?
And where does it come from?
And how does it get here?
And what is the conditions
in the markets?
And speaking to individual
households about their kind
of home economy and then
to shop keepers and people
in the market places, to farmers
to aid workers, to different NGO's
that are trying to facilitate
some sustainability or some --
just to keep Gaza fed under
its present circumstances.
And try to extrapolate sort of
beginning from the micro level
of these recipes in these individual
households, extrapolate outwards
and learn about the whole
food system and there
for necessarily the whole political
circumstances of the Gaza Strip.
What's happening there and intuit
or begin to understand why.
So we looked at industry.
This for example is a
picture of the industry
in Gaza is reduced
to almost nothing.
But this particular [inaudible]
factory was still operating.
So here are the great
machines that they had
for toasting the sesame seeds.
And a whole interesting discussion
about where do you get
the sesame seeds from?
How do they get through the borders?
Et cetera.
You can choose sort of almost
any mundane ingredient and from
that draw a very complete
picture of what's happening
in this tiny little
part of the world.
That's so embattled
and so constantly
under the magnifying
glass of geopolitics.
>> Laila El-Haddad: And so many
issues as Maggi talked about.
I don't -- I'm thinking in my mind,
like what's too political,
what's not?
But, you know, like
Maggi was saying,
it's kind of inescapably political.
Right? I mean the food
economy itself there, you know,
we talk in the book how it's --
Gaza itself is kind
of an experimented
post-modern colonialism.
But it is sort of one big
social experiment in the sense
that Everything that goes in and
out is rationed and calculated,
and it varies from week to week.
And you know, and there's
this whole, you know,
shadow government operating
as well beyond the current --
you have the UN, you
know, and the [inaudible].
Then you have the various
aid groups and NGO's.
And the aid economy,
you know, what's allowed
in and what's allowed out.
And how many people are
actually dependent on that.
And what -- how they use those
ingredients to then manufacture
or create all kinds of new dishes,
and substitute certain ingredients,
and what access they have
to what is available.
And you know, is a
whole other issue.
So we kind of weave together all
these various stories in the book
and -- I'm trying to
think of one example.
>> Maggi Schmitt: And with them
we also provide sort of profiles
of individuals who tell their
stories in the first person.
So it's an attempt to like
I said, document and kind
of formalize the recipes as
knowledge and the peculiarity
of Gazan cuisine, because as
Laila said, it really is different
from other regions of Palestine.
And very notably different from
other parts of the greater region.
So really recognizing that and
sharing that with the world.
>> Laila El-Haddad: And the ways --
we should probably mention some of
the ways in which it's different.
Because we do -- so what we try
to do is like we were saying,
is we have this sort of
documentary style photography.
We have the profiles
of the individuals
and the various text boxes and,
you know, analysis of the political
and economic situation and
everything that entails.
And then of course we have
the recipes themselves.
And some of what makes it
so different is the way that's it's
absorbed certain ingredients amongst
which are the use --
extensive use of spice.
Both actual spices and heat.
The peakensey of the cuisine
is very notable as well.
Mainly in the urban areas.
Much of Gaza of course is
rural or else descendants
of former villages and so forth.
And their cuisine is
also very different.
But it kind of incorporates --
it's a great place we say to
experience the cuisine of sort
of greater Palestine
within the context
of the small little tiny Gaza Strip.
Because so many Palestinians came
from elsewhere throughout
historic Palestine to Gaza.
So you have the peakensey of the
urban areas, and the sophistication,
and the extensive use of
spices which is again an ode
to Gaza's position in ancient
times along those trade routes.
And then you have sort of
the Mediterranean flavors.
You have the extensive use
of dill and dill seeds.
And very lemony sour flavors,
which again dates back
to sort of the Basit times.
Sour pomegranates, and
lemons, and tamarin,
and all these various flavors.
So it's a very urban -- herby
vibrant, you know, peakant cuisine.
But again, even in an area
small as Gaza it varies greatly
from like one mile to the next,
and people have very heated
conversations about like,
this is not how they
make it in our village.
You know, or we would never
dream of making Sumagia.
That's a Gaza City thing.
And we never use -- you
know, villagers would say
to us frequently, we
never use garlic.
Ew, garlic.
You know. [Inaudible] us
villagers only use onion.
And so it was really remarkable
how well preserved some
of these traditions were.
I just -- you know, from
one area to the next.
>> Maggi Schmitt: This was one of
the things that really surprised us
in the field work was
how faithfully and sort
of endogamically each village would
reproduce -- these are villages,
many of them that had been
destroyed after or in 1948,
and often the only trace left
of them was the taste of them.
And therefore you got a sense that
people understood themselves, cooks,
women understood themselves
as somehow the --
>> Laila El-Haddad: Keepers.
>> Maggi Schmitt: The
keepers, the safe guarders
of the only little intangible
heritage left of a village
of which no stone is
left, no evidence is left.
It's name's not on the map.
But we know that we make
lentils in this way.
You know? And that these
recipes were being perpetuated
from one generation to
the next in this way.
It was very beautiful and
very interesting to see
that these are not first generation,
these are second and third,
and sometimes fourth generation
that are perpetuating these specific
tastes of these specific villages,
and identifying them as such.
So that was one of
the many surprises
that awaited us in the fieldwork.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Right.
The regional specificity
of a lot of these dishes.
>> Maggi Schmitt: In general
in the fieldwork it was shocking
just how generous people were,
and we know -- we know that in
this region people are generous
with food in general.
And passionate about food in general
and proud of their food in general.
But we felt like it was quite a lot.
We were a little nervous when
we set off to do the field work
because speaking to publishers
with the idea in the United States,
mostly we got from sort of more
political publishing houses,
they said, ah how frivolous,
a cookbook.
And from more cookbook
publishing houses they said,
ye Palestine, Gaza, very political.
We don't want to touch it.
So we were nervous that we would
get sort of similar responses
from the people we
approached in our field work.
And on the contrary, it was a sort
of affirmation of our intuition
when we went and as soon
as we started asking people
about food they immediately
understood that if we're asking
about food we're also
really asking about --
or talking about family histories,
human dignity, cultural continuity,
sustainability, the present economy.
Like in Gaza everyone we spoke
to about this really
immediately captured the whole --
>> Laila El-Haddad: They
were head over heels.
I mean we --
>> Maggi Schmitt: Got
the whole idea.
>> Laila El-Haddad: I mean we
had trouble sort of -- yeah.
>> Maggi Schmitt: And we
had to fend off invitations.
>> Laila El-Haddad: We did.
We would be speaking to someone and
suddenly they would be pouring --
people would pop their heads out.
Let me offer you the
best way to make this.
>> Maggi Schmitt: Okra, okra.
No you make okra like this.
>> Laila El-Haddad: And
then they would -- yeah.
It was incredible and I mean it
really does speak to sort of again,
the very humanizing, you
know, aspect of all of this.
And we frequently say that
Gaza's besieged with media
in addition to many other things.
And people were always
kind of bracing themselves
to give us their rehearsed responses
to whatever question they
thought we were about to ask them
and were really pleasantly
surprised to find out that like no,
we actually want to know how, you
know, you make [foreign word].
But again, with the
understanding that all --
we're not like pretending
that none of this exists.
But getting to there through
a different window as it were.
And then, you know, I
mentioned a lot of --
how some of these dishes some
of their ingredients we
noticed had changed over time.
People frequently ask us about like
how have people sort of adapted?
And we like to say, you know,
that it's pretty remarkable how they
have managed to adapt given sort
of the impossible circumstances
under which they live.
And this is a good example.
This is a mushroom cultivation
facility that we went to,
and of course mushrooms aren't
ordinarily used in the cuisine,
but because of the very dire
conditions and the high rates
of food insecurity, you
know, many NGO's along
with the agricultural secretary
were struggling over --
for ways in which to -- through
which to supplement the --
people's inaccessibility to protein.
Right? Like fresh meat
and fish, and so on.
So they came up with this idea of
cultivating mushrooms and using
that as an income generation
scheme for women,
and giving them little recipes, you
know, to help them adapt to using,
incorporating the mushroom
in their food and so on.
But one very obvious
one also was the --
I should say, not the use but the
disuse of olive oil which is --
of course is a -- one of the --
the main fat, right in
Palestinian cuisine.
Now people we noticed mainly were
using it just to sort of drizzle
or finish certain dishes
and that's due to the --
again, the large rates
of food insecurity.
The prohibitive, you know,
price tag on olive oil now.
The fact that so many of those
groves, the trees are uprooted,
and the inaccessibility of course
between Gaza and the West Bank
where most of the olive trees grow.
So people have now swapped soy oil,
which is distributed by many --
much of the aid organizations.
Which of course, you know,
aid distribution is intended
for a short term emergency and in
Gaza it's become a long term thing.
And so that's just a whole
other sort of can of worms.
What happens -- what's the impact
of long term aid distribution
and dependence on a
population and how they eat?
Another good example is --
Maggi showed you the picture
of those two brothers --
well not that you would know
they're brothers, but they are,
and they're sort of
these entrepreneurs
that established the fish
farming industry in Gaza.
Which again, why would you need
fish farming in a coastal --
you wouldn't but again,
due to the restrictions
on the fishing zones off Gaza's
coast they became inventive,
innovative, and this sort
of, you know, took off.
I'm always careful
about my use of words.
Blew up. And the NGO secretary
adopted this very enthusiastically
and began to buy the fish from them
and distribute them to other farms
or NGO's to distribute to people.
And um --
>> Maggi Schmitt: And
they are characteristic --
I mean we like these stories of what
the sort of pop word in the world
of NGO's these days is
talking about resilience.
I have a lot of ambivalence
about this notion of resilience.
But we do like these
stories of individuals
who have found incredibly
inventive ways to get
around every obstacle that's put up.
And these guys besides being
just very charming and very funny
in themselves -- they get
giant electric blackouts
and they can't aerate the fish
tanks and the fish will, you know,
suffocate for lack of oxygen.
And so they invite all the
village kids to come over --
the kids from the neighborhood
come over
and swim in the pool and splash.
And they have splashing
competitions for the kids,
and that aerates the pools
and then the fish can breathe.
>> Laila El-Haddad: There's like
12-hour power outages in a row.
>> Maggi Schmitt: So that
sort of constant ability to --
okay, this is the situation, how do
-- and being very much on their feet
and coming up with solutions
that get around these obstacles.
With -- I mean I love that example
because invite all the kids to come
and have a splashing party?
Like it's not only getting around
a really serious material limit
to the infrastructural
problem, but also with joy,
with a sense of community, with like
let's have a splashing competition.
So, and we came again
and again upon this kind
of inventiveness and ingenuity.
And yeah, there are more
things about these guys story
that are relevant, but we
should probably stop and give
over the floor to questions.
But we have many many,
many, many more anecdotes.
We can keep going and going.
But should we pass the
floor to questions?
>> Laila El-Haddad:
This is an example
of the aid distribution we
were talking about which again,
something like 75% of the
population is a participant
in either the World
Food Organization,
the World Health Organization,
whatever it is, [inaudible].
There's food vouchers and coupons
and all this sort of, you know,
a whole intricate system network
through which aid is distributed
and there's constant
questions as to whether --
how the food aid packages
should be changed.
And I was shocked to
discover in writing, you know,
updating the second
edition of the book
that chickpeas were never
included in UN packages.
That was -- I was pretty
floored by that.
That seemed like sort
of a basic thing.
But again, a lot of
it is white sugar,
white flour, you know, soy oil.
These kinds of things.
[Inaudible] kind of --
>> Maggie Schmitt: With the
corresponding nutritional problems.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Right.
>> Maggie Schmitt: That generates.
Anyway, we should give
the floor to questions.
We're happy to -- yes please?
>> Well since there's two speakers
I get to ask two questions.
For Laila I really have to kind
of exonerate Anthony Bourdain,
who I went to see here
two weeks ago,
who said he always gets
asked about Andrew Zimmer.
So I'm going to ask you
about Anthony Bourdain.
How was his cultural sensitivity?
Because I take it that he's
somebody who is very open-minded
and really makes an effort
to give dignity to cultures.
And then for Maggi, Miami
has an ethnic cuisine.
Have you ever looked at
Miami's ethnic cuisine?
>> Maggi Schmitt: Miami
has many ethnic cuisines.
>> Even Chinese food, when I tell
people about Cuban Chinese food.
And then just to ask
both of you all,
do people depend on home gardens?
You know, how important
are those, you know,
things that they could
do in their own homes?
>> Laila El-Haddad: Yeah,
those are great questions.
So, in regards to Anthony Bourdain.
Yeah, I was a little
like nervous a first.
I didn't know what to expect.
I thought -- you know, I just
knew sort of his bad boy persona
and I should mention I had
my two daughters with me
and like my youngest
was four months old,
and then my other was I guess
five, and I had no one to help me.
I went there under really
sort of arduous circumstances
and I was then told to meet
him at a location in Gaza City.
And I kept getting told by the
producers, like no don't --
you can't bring the
baby, and this and that.
And come in your own car,
and you know, all the --
and so I was getting really
nervous this would be a very child
unfriendly operation.
And he -- you know, I
immediately met him and he --
you know, and then my -- at one
point during the shooting I had
to take my baby with me to nurse
her and she was freaking out,
and I didn't know what to do.
And I don't think people put two
and two together, but that was her
in the video and he just
picked her up and was just
like hushed her to sleep.
And so I was like, oh okay then.
So that was fantastic.
And he's like, I miss this age.
Because his daughter was
seven I guess at the time.
And so that was a real delight.
And you're absolutely right in the
sense that he's very comfortable,
you know, speaking not
only about all topics,
but respecting people and,
you know, their cultures.
And having an open mind
and open conversations.
And it was fantastic.
It was a really special
unique opportunity I think.
And I'm so glad it happened at
that precise moment in time.
It would have been impossible a
few months before and a few months
after due to all the
border closures and so on.
So it was great and I
was able to take him
to places I don't think they would
have been able to get to otherwise.
It was a really unique opportunity
and I was really nervous about how
or whether they would spin it sort
of in a certain way at the end.
Because I was only sort of part of
-- one part of the whole episode.
But overall I was, you know,
very pleased and very happy
that we had the chance
to take him through.
The only part we didn't get to
do was take him out into sea.
We were supposed to go out with
some fishermen but they deemed it
like too unsafe or
something at the time.
But in regards to the home gardens
and so forth, yeah absolutely.
We talk about that in the book.
People not having not only
dove coats, but rabbit --
there's little rabbit
rearing operations
and of course each one presents
its own set of challenges.
Access to water that isn't
completely, you know,
saline or being able to find,
you know, the proper feed
for chickens or whatever it is.
There's restrictions on what
comes in and out to the strip.
And, you know, the heat
and so on and so forth.
But certainly you'll
find everyone --
even if they have a small little
strip of land will have something
on their rooftop or if they
have just a tiny little section
of land will be growing something.
But again, it is a very
densely populated place
with very limited space.
And not everyone has the luxury
to be living in a building
with a rooftop obviously.
But they do what we --
what they can I think.
And part of the problem
is that sometimes
that knowledge isn't inherited due
to the sort of constant, you know,
misplacements and migrations,
and so forth.
And so we were always, you know,
very pleased to find certain cases
where that knowledge was given
from -- passed down from an uncle,
to a mother, to -- but often
times they just didn't know how
to do this.
And so they -- in one
particular case they --
one NGO or community center grouped
together sort of grandmothers
with younger women and
the grandmothers kind
of taught the younger women how
to care for the rabbits and how
to raise for them --
raise them and so on.
>> Maggi Schmitt: So
yeah, lots and lots
of micro sustainability initiatives.
And then a much bigger debate at the
level of the Ministry of Agriculture
or how much too really
push for sustainability.
Because any hope of sustainability
in a territory like Gaza that is
so tiny, so totally
lacking in water.
I mean the big crisis
there is countdown
to doomsday in terms of water.
There is no water.
They've over -- the aquifer of the
whole region has been overdrawn.
The saline water is
entering from the sea.
Like you could push for
sustainability but A,
the territories just not big
enough to ever provide the calories
that population needs,
and B, at great --
like the more agriculture
you do the more risk
of over drying the aquifer.
So there are lots of
different parameters.
So on an individual like household
level everybody is drawing
on every resource they can to
raise pigeons, to raise rabbit's,
to grow mushrooms in the closets,
to grow, you know, herbs in barrels.
>> Laila El-Haddad:
But don't you feel --
like sometimes I feel the average
American household can learn
so much from --
>> Maggi Schmitt: Absolutely.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Or whoever.
There was one woman we visited in
a tiny little space like cooked
up a storm, like a three course
meal, and you know, the grey water
from washing the parsley went to her
garden and the parsley stalks went
to the chickens outdoors, and
you know, everything was done
in a completely sustainable way
in this one woman operation.
And it's just incredible.
>> Maggi Schmitt: Absolutely.
So yeah, and as for
the Cuban Chinese.
I'd love to go back and do this
kind of ethnographic in Miami.
I left Miami when I was 13
so I've never really
lived there as an adult.
But one of these days I'll go back
to Miami and do something like this.
Because it really is an
unbelievably rich, weird,
idiosyncratic, interesting place.
>> I lived on South
Beach for five years.
>> Maggi Schmitt: There's
a lot going on there.
In any city block there's a lot
of stories to tell in Miami.
>> Thank you.
>> Maggi Schmitt: Other question?
Yes?
>> I was intrigued by your
mentioning the regional differences.
That the food in Gaza is
different from other parts
of the Palestinian region.
Could you give some
concrete examples of that?
>> Maggi Schmitt: Of course.
Very roughly I mean there are lots
of different regional
differences even
within Gaza as Laila was saying.
Like between families that
originally of the sort
of farming village
interior, the hill towns.
Families that are from
the coastal --
the sort of more urban
coastal places like very --
even within Gaza there are
very striking differences.
But in the north of
Palestine for example,
there's much more use of yogurts.
They do not like spicy food.
Like spicy in the sense of hot.
At all. There's in general, a much
lesser use of all kinds of spices,
both aromatic spices and
like spicy hot spices.
And a lot of use of yogurts.
It's much more similar
to the Lebanese or --
>> Laila El-Haddad: Seems to be
a north/south thing doesn't it?
>> Maggi Schmitt: North/south thing.
>> Laila El-Haddad: I mean
the most obvious example --
if I was to give you
like one example.
It's sort of the most
stereotypically
but it does hold true, is
the use of the chili pepper.
So they use a lot of chili
peppers in the Gaza region,
both in green form
and sun-dried form.
You know, chili flakes and chili
sauce, and all sorts of things.
And there's a really
famous pounded salad similar
to a salsa almost I would say,
called [foreign word] Gazan salad
or dead guy, which means pounded
that's made with dill, tomatoes,
garlic or onions depending
on who you speak to.
Another very heated
debate as we learned.
And then chili pepper,
green chili peppers.
Very fiery hot chili peppers.
That seemed to be sort of an
indigenous variety [inaudible].
Obviously before it
came to the Americas.
But that's one obvious example.
Again, other's -- Fellaheen will
tell you, we don't -- they don't --
they're not very fond
of the chili pepper.
Their tradition was one of more --
much more mild seasonal
flavors of root vegetables
and [foreign word],
and things like that.
But the chili pepper and then dill.
The extensive use of dill in
green form and then dill seed
as well, is used -- yeah, sorry?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
No dill, dill.
Like dill weed or dill greens.
>> What is the Arabic [inaudible]?
>> Laila El-Haddad: Ah,
what is it in Arabic?
Okay, in Egypt and
elsewhere they call it Shebat.
In Gaza they call it Jirada.
And yeah -- and the dill seed
is called [foreign word].
Right. Leave it to the Palestinians
with their sick sense of humor.
That means locust eye.
So because it looks
like a -- I know, right.
And yeah, they use that a lot.
The other thing I would say is --
I'm trying to think
off the top of my head.
>> Maggi Schmitt: And also seafood.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Right, that
was what I was going to mention.
Right.
>> Maggi Schmitt: Gaza is
the last little piece of --
of what is presently Palestine
that has access to the sea.
So there is a historic
seafood cuisine in the region,
but very few Palestinians
in the region presently
have access to the sea.
Gaza has maintained a lot of
the sort of high-end, elaborate,
you know, stuffed and rolled,
and fried, and breaded --
these sort of very elaborate,
very sophisticated seafood
cuisine is actually form Yafa.
Yafa was the great sort of city
-- cosmopolitan city on the sea.
Pre '48 Palestine.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Many of those
Palestinians from Yafa came by sea,
fled to Gaza in 1948
and ended up there.
Yeah.
>> Maggi Schmitt: And so there is
significant Yafa population in Gaza
and they've really
maintained that seafood cuisine
and those seafood traditions.
So yeah, the -- and
you talk to the --
>> Laila El-Haddad: Everything from
fish, calamari, you know, octopus.
All sorts of things
you'll find there.
>> Maggi Schmitt: You talk to
Palestinians from the West Bank
and in Israel, et cetera, and many
from before the borders were closed,
many have this sort of romantic
memories of going to the beach
at Gaza, and having
the seafood at Gaza.
It's like a thing, that
you went down to Gaza to go
to the beach and eat seafood.
That was a -- you know, a lovely
family Sunday for many years
until the borders were closed.
So it's very famous for
its seafood and rightly so,
because it's spectacular.
>> Laila El-Haddad: There's
also a lot of these, you know,
dishes that we never knew
quite how to categorize them.
Mush bowls.
>> Maggi Schmitt: Mush.
>> Laila El-Haddad: No they're not
-- come on, give them their due.
They're very nice.
But they're basically like one pot
-- like they're cooked in one pot
and made with either a
green or a pulse like,
you know, Sumagia's a good one.
It's made with charred
chickpeas, lamb meat.
Usually a [foreign word]
thickened with taina and sumac --
tartness from the sumac berry.
And then kind of all cooked
together until it thickened.
Pour it into bowls and then eaten
with bread or distributed to family.
And there's other's.
There's [foreign word]
there's, you know, fogiya.
And they're all cooked, poured into
bowls, you know, allowed to kind
of congeal and then eaten.
That's something that seems to be --
>> Maggi Schmitt: Scooped up.
>> Laila El-Haddad:
Scooped up with bread.
That seems to be peculiar or, you
know, unique to that area as well.
>> That does sound
tough [inaudible].
>> Laila El-Haddad: The what?
>> That does sound --
>> Laila El-Haddad: Right,
yeah, absolutely yeah.
>> Maggie Schmitt: It's an
Egyptian type pronunciation
and in Gaza it's more --
>> Laila El-Haddad: No, is it?
No. It's not.
That's different.
No, in Egypt it's - no, in --
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
[ Multiple Speakers ]
In Gaza it's yeah --
>> Du-ca becomes du-gah.
Sumatia becomes sumagia.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah?-
>> I was actually interested
in thinking about substitution.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Ah right, yeah.
>> So in your book do you
mention the original recipe
and various substitutions?
>> Laila El-Haddad: Yeah.
>> Maggie Schmitt:
This was a big debate.
We were all the time sort
of going back and forth
between a sort official of memory of
like how things were supposed to be.
Like really this should
be made with barley.
Maybe this should be
made with [foreign word].
But now we make it with, you know,
imported FAO short grain rice.
Or this kind of substitution.
So we try to represent both.
In some cases we specifically
say like this is a dish of memory
that should be done like this,
but none of these ingredients
are presently available.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Like
for the most part we --
>> But the audience is not in Gaza.
>> Laila El-Haddad: No,
no, for the most part we --
no, we include the original
version of the dish.
But then just for the sake of
sort of representing this --
you know, this reality we
include like two or three recipes
that emerged in the aftermath of
1948 either during the exodus itself
or that continue to be made.
Very simple dishes that -- and
we say, this emerged, you know,
and is -- was created through
sort of patchwork of, you know,
ingredients and what not.
But no, we do include
the authentic --
>> Several.
>> Laila El-Haddad: We do.
We have -- we have
several recipes, right.
So, you know, we -- there are a
couple of recipes too that are sort
of in disuse, that are no longer
made or not very frequently
from certain -- like from
[inaudible] and other places.
Sort of ceremonial dishes that we
thought were really interesting
to record sort of for, you
know, historical reference,
but that most people because
there aren't these big gathering
in [inaudible] in Gaza
right, don't make.
But one example is [foreign
word] which is eaten like a feta.
It's made with [foreign word]
but it's like feta, a big platter
and everyone kind of gets around it.
It's made with wheat --
during the wheat harvest.
So we include a few
references to dishes like that.
But for the most part we
try to sort of remain true
to the original versions
of the recipe.
Yeah.
>> One more question.
>> Nawal Kawar: Are we done?
>> Laila El-Haddad: While
we're waiting for questions,
I was going to mention one
more thing that is unique
to the way the dishes
are prepared in Gaza.
Is the extensive use of the
zubdiah, the mortar and pestle.
That -- I don't know if we
have a picture of it here.
That is fashioned from
this really rich red clay
and you'll see mortar's and pestles
obviously throughout the world
and elsewhere in Palestine, but
what makes this unique is again,
it's made from clay
from a lemonwood pestle.
It's used to prep ingredients.
It's used to cook in.
It's used to serve other dishes in.
It's ubiquitous, absolutely
ubiquitous.
You'll see it in every household.
Families retain it for generations
and consider it sort of a member
of their family and we thought
that was really kind
of a lovely anecdote.
>> What about the popular dish?
Do you have it in your cookbook?
>> Laila El-Haddad: I'm sure we
do, but I don't know what it is.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Ah right.
>> And then you have the
fire and then you put
in a clay pot the rice --
>> Laila El-Haddad: Ah yes.
Idra. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
>> I can't remember.
>> Laila El-Haddad:
Yeah, Idra, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, of course we have that.
That was sort of one of
the first ones I mentioned.
And I know there's
debate about -- yeah.
And we never claim that
a particular dish is
like only exclusively made in Gaza.
You know, that would
be absolutely absurd.
And so we do mention that this is
made in Hebron and made elsewhere.
And in Gaza they have
their own spin on it.
But it's certainly kind of the go
to ceremonial dish for weddings
and funerals, and this
sort of thing.
[Speaking in foreign language], you
know, birth ceremonies and so on.
And it used to be made in the way
that you mention and when we went
and did the field work we found
one remaining oven, right,
like a community oven
where they were still made
in these big clay vessels and
placed in a brick oven I suppose.
And that's still going based
on my most recent, you know,
contact with the family there.
But for the most part it's not made
in the very traditional way anymore.
People will usually take the
meat to the oven and say,
can you make me enough for
200 people for this party,
and they'll give them to them in
little foil packets and so on.
>> It's not the same.
>> Laila El-Haddad: No I -- it is.
Well this oven is really
good though.
This is the one remaining
oven that does it in the --
sort of in the clay
vessels still in the way,
and they pour the [foreign
word] on top.
So this is actually awfully good.
But you really have to go out I
think to the more remote areas
of the Gaza Strip and
the Bedouin areas
to find them doing
the fire pit thing.
And they'll do -- a good example of
that is the dish that they showed
on the Anthony Bourdain
show, [foreign word].
And a lot of the, you know,
descendants of, you know,
[inaudible] some of the Bedouin
clans will still make those dishes
in the fire pit and so forth.
But not in the city.
>> The nice thing about this one
is when it is cooked they get it
out from the pit and they use
trays, they [inaudible] it
and they come and knock
out the clay.
>> Maggi Schmitt: Yeah.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Laila El-Haddad:
It's fantastic yeah.
>> It's unbelievable.
>> Laila El-Haddad: They do
this -- they do break these too.
>> Maggi Schmitt: These
urns are made to be broken.
>> Laila El-Haddad:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Maggie Schmitt: So they
-- but yeah, this is now --
this is a commercial oven that these
urns that you see, they fill them
with the rice, the meat, the
spices, and then they cook slowly
in a stone oven which produces
a sort of similar effect
to the embers in the ground.
And then as a serving
thing they break it open.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, it's incredible.
>> Nawal Kawar: All right --
>> Laila El-Haddad: Yeah,
you're making us hungry.
>> Maggi Schmitt: It's lunchtime.
>> Nawal Kawar: Thank you very much.
We have the book at
the end of the program
for anybody who wants to buy it.
I hope they are here.
They are?
>> Maggi Schmitt: Oh are they?
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Okay great.
>> Nawal Kawar: Plenty are there.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Fantastic.
>> Maggi Schmitt: Thank you so much.
>> Laila El-Haddad: Thank you.
Happy to entertain more questions.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.